تحرك الفلسطيني ليلى صار مغامره تؤدي اما
للاستشهاد او الاسرى لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي
وشهود عيان جنود الاحتلال وهم يطلقون
الرصاصه على مركبه شاب وفتاه فلسطينيين في
بلده بيتونيا غربيه رام الله اعدمت الفتاه
واصيب الشاب
اللي جنبه اللي هي الشهيده مباشره
جنت فيه قوات الاحتلال حمله اعتقالات في
بيتونيا وفي قره ومدن فلسطينيه
كل ليله حملات الاعتقالات ومنذ بدايه
العام ارتفعت الى اكثر من سته الاف حاله
في خضم مواجهه شعبيه متواصله على المستوى
السياسي اثمرت الجهود الدبلوماسيه
الفلسطينيه الدوليه تبنيه لجنه المسائل
السياسيه وان نهائي الاستعمار في الامم
المتحده اربعه قرارات لصالح فلسطين
باعتماد اللجنه قرار فلسطين بطلب فتوى
قانونيه ورايا استشاريا من محكمه العدل
الدوليه حول ماهيه وجود الاحتلال
الاستعماري الاسرائيلي على ارض دوله
فلسطين بما فيها القدس
بقياديه قد يكون من بينها وزاره الدفاع في
عضو الكنيسه المتطرف ايثمار
وحتى قبل تشكيل الحكومه يطالب بان يشمل
الاتفاق الائتلافي بنده عقوبه الاعدام
لفلسطين نفذوا هجمات ضده اهداف اسرائيل
امام حملات الدهم والاعتقال الاسرائيليه
اليوميه المتزايده ومع سقوط الشهداء يؤكد
الفلسطينيه ان انهاء الانقسام الداخلي
وتعزيز المقاومه على الارض من اهم الخطوات
للوقوف في وجه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده التي توصف بعض احبابها بالمتطرفه
الجزيره رام الله